let's go to Marcus from is it Manitoba
or or met uh Manitoba yeah Marcus from
Manitoba welcome to the program David
sir yes yes it is from Manitoba in fact
what's on your mind
yeah yeah and I'm coming to you
with tears in my eyes over this latest
news from Fox News that uh air star
Tucker Carlson has been rooted right
here
and I'm wondering just how
it got to the point where this guy is
was just sort of being given the
platform to
say some of like the most extreme and
even within like the circles of American
conservatism uh
quite unpopular things
like seemingly just without any
reprimand from
the organization he was working for
you're saying how did how was Tucker
able to say the things he said without
being reprimanded by Fox
well I I guess I'm just wondering like
how did Fox News not realize that the
things that Tucker Carlson as well as
you know their other hosts for saying
we're going to get them sued eventually
well it's more complicated than that
because the most of the trouble that
Tucker caused for Fox is not really
related to the things he said yes he
played koi with the Dominion in 2020
election stuff and that was part of the
lawsuit but it was less about what
Tucker himself was necessarily saying
the lawsuit for discrimination from a
staffer former staffer doesn't relate to
what Tucker said on air the potentially
forthcoming lawsuit from rayap's wood
but we'll have to wait and see whether
that's filed so I think it's a little
more complicated than that I mean Fox's
primary concern is ratings and Tucker
had good ratings so that's fundamentally
the most important thing
I guess so yeah that's true but I
suppose more broadly I I'm just kind of
wondering like who Tucker Carlson's
audience is apparently has a huge
audience
um but like the things he was saying
especially about like Russia and Ukraine
it's it's not something that like any of
the other like mainstream well certainly
not mainstream Republicans but even uh
it's not like uh it's it's the he's
taking the Russian position he has said
that he is like pro-putin essentially
yeah he didn't say that but he certainly
made some strange comments about it
listen his audience is is Right Wingers
and there's a desire for this contrarian
sort of Maga style right wing ISM which
often ends up using populist rhetoric
and being a little more deferential to
Global authoritarians than you might
think so in that sense it's not that out
of left field
I guess so
one of my favorite sort of tropes that
you see on the very far right
um you know among uh people like like
Matt Yates and such which he kind of uh
was demonstrated in that one uh meeting
of him in that that one clip where he uh
used
uh Chinese propaganda
as evidence that the US was funding the
Azog Battalion in Ukraine not realizing
that it was Chinese propaganda and then
it was embarrassed when he was because
like
um or when it was shown to him that it
was Chinese propaganda
yes that absolutely that absolutely did
happen but that that's a bit of a
different topic Marcus thank you so much
for the call I'm going to move on
because I've got a bunch of people
waiting but you certainly covered a
gamut of issues and I really do uh I
really do appreciate that let's go to
Andy from Sweden Andy welcome to the
David Pacman show what's on your mind
today
and please unmute yourself Andy so that
we can hear you
hello David can you hear me yes I can
I'm a big fan from Sweden and I have a
question to you in two parts if that's
okay yeah of course uh who is your
favorite chess player that's my favorite
I I don't have a favorite chess player I
I uh I'd have to I don't know I don't
think I have just one
I don't think honestly
are you watching the world championship
I have not I have no I've been so busy
what's going is anything notable
happening
I mean it's very tight very tight right
now between nepomyachi from Russia and
dingley run from China okay I'll try to
I'll try to follow a little bit if I can
and so you can you can watch on
chess.com uh they have a stream right
now beautiful uh and the second part is
who do you think is the best chess
playing Washington in terms of you know
in in Congress and in the Senate I have
absolutely no idea do any of them even
play
I have no idea maybe they play 40 chess
right right okay thank you Andy from
Sweden thank you I uh very much
appreciate that let's end there and not
press our luck we will take calls again
and we will do so next week we will take
a break and be back right after this